As an Iranian refugee
who grew up in rural east Tennessee,
and someone who studied,
lived and worked in over 30 countries,
I thought I knew how to navigate
across cultures and languages.
I was wrong.
There I was, day one of business school,
getting my bearings
and hearing an alien language.
It wasn't English, French,
or my native Persian.
It was a bouillabaisse of languages,
jargon from across
the organizational multiverse:
the corporate world,
the nonprofit sphere,
international development
and the public sector.
It was weird.
In business school, I thought
I'd learn about leadership styles.
What I found were leadership languages.
And I learned that by becoming
conversant in these languages
that I could communicate with
and contribute to all of these worlds.
So how does one become multilingual?
Here's my story.
In college, I went to West Africa
to study microfinance
and economic empowerment.
Seeing a large public health need,
I cofounded and led a nonprofit
collecting medical supplies and money.
We saw what collective action could yield,
and we were creative with our advocacy
and our fundraising,
with campaigns like "Band Aids for Benin."
Along the way, I studied
different leadership styles:
autocratic, democratic,
laissez faire, servant, collaborative,
transformational and more.
I read books, attended trainings
and I even had the privilege
to study with some of the greats
and to work with General Colin
Powell and Dr. Maya Angelou.
After all of this,
I became convinced that there's no
best type of leadership.
So many of us just default
to one style or another,
similar to how we're born
with our native tongue.
But this default style
doesn't work in every situation.
Many leaders obsess over leadership style
when really they just need
to get over themselves.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Sorry, leader, it's not about you.
(Laughter)
What's more useful is to adapt
and personalize your leadership
to be the leader the situation
and the people involved need.
It's not so much style as language,
the living vernacular of each discrete
community and culture.
The successful leader will aspire
to be multilingual,
to speak fluently with all groups
and to translate among them.
In 2012, while working
at the Omidyar Network,
I was one of the sponsors
of a two-year study
of 12 impact investing funds.
One of the "ahas" of this project
was that the most successful funds
were those led by multilingual leaders,
people that could communicate across
the corporate, nonprofit, philanthropic
and public policy perspectives.
These leaders also made sure
that others on their team
were multilingual.
This came to me as a bit of a surprise.
I expected the secret sauce to be
in sophisticated financial modeling
or some other type of complex analysis.
According to this study,
the multilingual leader
will describe their work
as being unremittingly
financially driven -- business speak,
moving the needle on social
and environmental challenges --
nonprofit and philanthropic speak,
while addressing systemic
market failures --
public policy speak.
The study further found
the need to be conversant
into four industry languages.
Those are finance, nonprofit, government
and international development.
The multilingual leader
was something that seemed
very familiar to me.
This really rang true
based on my own experience
of patchworks across these sectors,
and it took me back to that first
weird day in business school.
Now that we've described the how,
let us turn to the what.
Where should leaders focus?
I will modestly propose three topics
that cut across issues,
and together we'll double-click
on one of them.
Data, climate, power.
How each of these sectors measure
the impact and even the timing,
the tempo and the tools
that they use for each
could not be more different.
Say you're the private sector at one end.
You have accounting on a daily, a weekly,
a monthly and quarterly increments.
The public sector.
You're working on multi-year
election cycles.
The nonprofit and philanthropic sector,
well, you may give yourself 15 years
or even a generation to reach a goal.
Yet all of these sectors
must come together
to reach these outcomes.
To make it real,
let's look together about how
these sectors can come together
to address power
with the focus on gender equality.
Say you're a public sector leader.
You have the unique ability to create
equity, a level playing field,
so everyone has a fair shot.
You can create regulations and incentives
to increase the use of gender data.
You can set goals for women
on boards and in public office.
You can practice gender budgeting
and you can mandate paid care.
Say you're a leader
in the business sector.
You can design products and services
that unleash the economic power
of the female customer.
You can fortify and diversify
your supply chain
with women-owned businesses,
and you can invest
in your female talent pipeline
with pay equity
and leadership opportunities
so that your corporate decisions
are more inclusive.
Or maybe you work in philanthropy
or international development.
You can help remove the barriers,
whether formal or informal,
that influence how power is distributed.
You can fund the research and training
that both the public and the private
sector need to do their part.
You can fund campaigns
and grassroots efforts
that influence social and cultural norms.
And you can help get women
in decision-making roles
in their households, in their communities,
in their countries and in economies.
The multilingual leader can be conversant
and use the languages
of all of these sectors
to identify the root causes,
and then collaborate together
to find the solutions
to these complex issues.
So here is over 20 years of experience
distilled into one sentence.
Don't fret over your leadership styles,
focus on your leadership languages.
So over to you, leader.
Which languages
are you going to learn next?
Thank you.
(Applause)